à samsung samsung samsung la samsung tu
nous régale on parle aujourd'hui de deux
nouveaux modèles super intéressant dans
la gamme pliable dans la gamme z galaxy
z telle qu'on l'appelle chez samsung il
ya eu du changement je sais pas si vous
avez fait gaffe au début il y avait le
samsung stèle flood ensuite on a appelé
ça le z folle placer les épaules de deux
derniers modèles en tout cas que j'ai eu
et qui est super intéressant et lens
parle du z folle de trois et on se parle
du z flip 3 alors vous laissez pas
tromper il n'y a pas eu cette flip de
l'année dernière début d'année dernière
vous avez emmené à l'époque où je
pouvais vous emmener on était parti à
san francisco on avait découvert cette
free
a été présenté le nouveau galaxy z trip
non moi je trouve ça vachement
intéressant parce que les smartphones
pliable en rien le généraliser ces qui
venaient à leur encontre parce qu'on a
eue avec le fold l'année dernière et là
le z flip l'idée que c'est qu'il devient
réfléchir pour amar formant un peu plus
compact d'ailleurs dit le maire vous
tout de suite en commentaire est ce que
vous êtes plutôt team z fog ou est-ce
que vous êtes plutôt team et flip marqué
le mois dès maintenant contre
[Musique]
posez-moi dès maintenant toutes vos
questions sur ses smartphones en bas en
commentaire comme ça je vous y
répondrait dans ma vie des hôtels dans
mes vidéos tests le zèle folle de trois
il ya une superbe évolution une très
très très belle évolution déjà il ya un
truc assez intéressant qui dago partout
c'est que vous avez des écrans 120 air
de tous les côtés ça c'est sur les
épaules de 3 mais c'est également sur le
set flip 3 ce qui est super bien
justement avec le fait d'avoir intégré
du 120 hertz adaptatif adaptatif ça veut
dire vous n'avez pas due forme
d'alliance tout le temps lorsque votre
application nécessite 60 hertz vous
aurez 60 hertz du 80 derrière vous
auriez 90 1 200 hertz ou d'or du 100 m
l'idée c'est ça va éviter que ça
consomme trop puisque le centre arrière
sont en permanence à venir consommer
davantage et réduire l'autonomie c'est
donc vachement le même temps votre faute
vous ayez à l'extérieur et à l'intérieur
du 100 m mais également sur gênés flip à
l'intérieur uniquement à l'extérieur n'a
absolument aucun intérêt sur les aides
flip que vous ayez du sang variante est
ce qu'on voit et ce qui est vachement
bien avec le z fold c'est qu'ils ont
vraiment voulu mettre le paquet sur le
côté cinéma et notamment avec ces toutes
nouvelles technologies qui traîne depuis
super longtemps et qui est intéressante
et qui arrive enfin chez samsung du
moins c'est la caméras planquées sous
l'écran souvenez vous on revient
décembre 2020 je vous ai présenté un
smartphone zte qui s'appelle l'axone 20
l'axone 20 cas ce qu'ils faisaient il
est bien il vous présenter la première
caméras planquées sous l'écran ici pas
d'encoches pas de bulle pas de points
sont finies la discussion sur la place
de l'encoche la taille de l'encoche une
ou deux caméras à l'intérieur la
question ne se pose plus tout est
intégré directement sous l'écran de
façon transparente on ne voit plus rien
mais malgré tout la caméra est bien
présente elle existe elle est sous
l'écran mais elle est complètement
invisible en résulta t pâte d'un goût
dingo ce n'est pas fou fou et on
attendait avec impatience en tout cas
moi j'attendais j'ai pas vous d'ailleurs
duclos moi j'attendais vraiment avec
impatience d'avoir une caméras planquées
sous l'écran signé samsung enfin j'ai
envie de dire enfin elle arrive là tout
de suite en 2021 en ou 2020 alors on la
retrouve à l'intérieur de son smartphone
comme pour venir la cacher pour finir un
grand écran complètement et merci pour
me regarder ses films et séries donc ça
c'est très très très cool ça ça me plaît
nous pour autant s'est pas complètement
abouti qu'est-ce qu'on l'attend tu
ouvrais d'une nouvelle technologie comme
ça qu'est ce qu'on attend d'une caméras
planquées sous l'écran on attend qu'elle
fasse le job à 100% je veux que la
caméra soit planqué sous l'écran c'est à
dire que je ne veux plus la voir je ne
veux plus voir rien du tout ici on la
voit on la devine pas tout le temps mais
par moments et un petit peu trop à mon
goût pour ce soir complètement réussi
alors c'est super bien attention une
belle prouesse technologique que nous
fait samsung ici mais pour autant à il
manque ce petit truc tard ce qui me fait
dire qu'aujourd'hui et bien cette
technologie telle qu'on la retrouve
aujourd'hui inséré dans cette folle de 3
est une belle technologie de transition
c'est le début en fait on voit que c'est
le début de la caméra planqué sous
l'écran et comme bien souvent au début
de technologie et bien là il manque un
petit truc sur les épaules de 4 je ne
doute pas que ce sera super bien
planqués et probablement également sur
le s 22 qu'on devrait retrouver en début
d'année prochaine à noter que pour cette
caméra qui est planqué sous l'écran on
n'est pas sur une caméra fou fou c'est
du 4 mégapixels on ouvre à f 1.8 on
n'est pas sur un truc absolument dingue
pour faire de la conférence lorsque vous
allez venir travailler pourquoi pas au
collaborer ou appeler des amis ou de la
famille ça fonctionnera pour faire des
photos avec votre caméra de celle fils
qu'on va venir ici vous recommander
c'est de prendre de le plier et de fabry
toutefois que ces deux caméras là ou
alors pourquoi pas vous laisser comme ça
et vous utilisez ces caméras là pour
prendre celle fillette retour moniteur
ça sera ça la meilleure solution les
écrans ici tous les côtés cd amoled 2 x
dernière techno d'écran de samsung qui
marche super bien super bowl et tailles
d'écran restes conservés de tous les
côtés ça ne change absolument pas les
formats ne change pas au travail qu'a
fait samsung c'est d'améliorer les
matériaux en indiquant qu' 80% plus
résistant sur son sexe vol de 3 par
rapport à la génération précédente on
est un corning gorilla glass victimes
pour le rendre encore plus solide et on
a un aluminium ces armes hors aluminium
qui va également contribuer à le rendre
un peu plus le g mais vraiment
globalement pas grand chose mais un peu
plus résistant tout cas c'est ce que
nous annonce samsung tout ça on le
regardera très très très prochainement
lors du test on vous invite dès
maintenant à venir vous abonnez vous
cliquez sur le petit bouton rouge si ce
n'est pas déjà fait vous actionnez la
cloche comme ça vous serez notifié dès
qu'une vidéo arrivera et surtout lorsqu
on testera ses produits croyais moi on
va tester en long en large et en travers
et on testera également les mondes
pascal et watch series quatre qui sont
là et qui sont super intéressante on va
beaucoup plus loin il ya une nouvelle
expérience logiciel il ya un gros focus
sur le sport sur la santé mais sans le
regarder un peu plus tard dans good plus
abonnez vous il ya tout qui super bien
qu'on trouve sur les deux modèles le
flip et le foll c'est la première fois
qu'un smartphone pliable va voir un
indice d'étanchéité on est sûr de l'ip
et x8 alors si ça vous parle pas l'épée
de suite vous pouvez l'immerger pendant
une demi-heure à 1,5 m dans l'eau douce
autant dire vous n'avez pas les vous
baigner avec mais ça devient plus
rassurant on va te vois qu'un vrai
travail qui a été fait de ce côté là
pour avoir cette certification pourquoi
ça me plaît bien puisqu'on parle d'un
grand écran parle également de gaming il
nous faut de la perte mme ans derrière
ils ont mis ce cadre plus puissants
aujourd'hui enfin quasiment certain
dragon 888 avec 12 viendra vous avez
soit 256 go de stockage soit 512 le
tarif dans quelques instants on a des
haut parleurs stéréo pour maximiser
l'expérience de 6 des navettes du dolby
axon voyez l'idée vraiment là pour
apporter son grand écran une fois de
plus pour aller plus loin et vous de la
performance au niveau du cinéma au
niveau de la caméra qui se plante pour
faire apparaître uniquement un bel écran
samsung persiste et signe pour aller
dans cette idée du grand écran
totalement immersif sur l'idée fausse a
vraiment bien le produit hyper cool
hyper sexy il manque des deux pitres uc
le petit truc c'est sept caméras
planquées sous l'écran une fois qu'elle
voudra complètement invisible là je
dirais banques aux us c'est génial
samsung a lancé un nouveau format avec
ses smartphones pliable et notamment
avec les épaules y avait des soucis
d'intégration au niveau de certains
logiciels sur instagram notamment des
grandes bandes noires sur le côté c'est
pas terrible ici samsung vient pour
travailler avec microsoft google et
notamment instagram convenir mieux
améliorer l'expérience logiciel donc on
aura une expérience notamment sur
instagram complètement optimisé
profitera tout l'écran on n'aura plus
ces bandes doit donc assez cool vous
l'avez vu il n'ya pas de gamme note
cette année il n'y a pas de smartphone
dédié avec un stylet alors bien
évidemment on peut avoir un stylet avec
son ex 21 on peut venir acheter en plus
le stylet et on peut faire exactement la
même chose avec son cette folle 3 et
uniquement à que cette folle 3 vous avez
deux styles et un style est spécialement
conçu pour cette folle de 3 c'est le fun
edition 49 euros ici vous avez pas de
bluetooth donc ce n'est pas pour venir
commander votre smartphone avec votre
bluetooth par contre vous avez un
deuxième c'est le s pen pro l'huile
coûteront 99 euros et vous allez pouvoir
venir utiliser différents appareils une
tablette une table s7 et pouvoir
utiliser un s-21 ultra pourquoi pas un
hôte directement ici avec votre espèce
est uniquement le professionnel en
bluetooth 2 1 c'est plutôt intéressant
de voir que et bien effectivement on dit
qu'on avait un très grand écran a donc
provenir l'utiliser pour la vraie
productivité cette fois ci donc si vous
souhaitez griffonné dessinée prendre des
notes partager grâce à votre style et
grâce à votre espèce est bien vrai
pouvoir le faire grâce aux est folle de
3 et uniquement aux est folle de 3,2
pour y ranger son style et samsung nous
a créé un étui dans lequel vous venez
mettre votre stylet sur l'extérieur
alors l'idée est là mais là où on avait
un vrai avantage avec la gamme note on
venait met son style est directement
dans le smartphone là c'est plus le cas
vous le mettez derrière vous de
couverture qui bouge un peu tous les
côtés je reçois pas hyper hyper cali
pour voir qu'on est sur un smartphone à
plus de 1700 euros donc ça c'est dommage
et c'est là où on voit effectivement les
limites de ne pas avoir cette gamme dote
de ne pas pouvoir ranger ce style est
facilement en tout cas ici au niveau du
z folle de 3 donc on va vraiment que
samsung a vraiment mis le paquet au
niveau du cinéma du divertissement la
productivité avec cette folle de troie
qui devient aujourd'hui l'appareil
numéro un en termes de productivité chez
samsung il vient donc déclassé la gamme
note qui existe et continuera peut-être
à exister allez savoir donc aujourd'hui
la vraie productivité se joue sur le
cette folle de trois et non plus sur les
smartphones de la gamme note qu on
pouvait retrouver avant on peut la voir
également bien évidemment je l'aï dit
sur elle ce matin ultra mais ça c'est
une autre histoire alors parlons
maintenant du set flip qui a vraiment
été changés ce qui est beaucoup
intéressant c'est l'écran extérieur
c'est un écran de notification c'est pas
un écran qu'on va venir utiliser pour
venir jouer à des jeux et compagnies non
c'est un écran pour venir voir un
message pour actionner la caméra pour
recevoir en retour aussi vous allez
venir faire une une photo avec cet écran
il est plus grand on passe de 1,1 pousse
sur l'écran du z flip à 1,9 pousse sur
le z philippe iii nous ça c'est bien
pour autant ça reste un écran de
notification il plus grand plus
confortable on peut faire des choses
avec mais le grand bénéfice se trouve à
l'intérieur alors si samsung a fait
chaud de permettre de caméras planquées
sous l'écran ils ont gardé vraiment ça
uniquement pour les épaules de 3 et puis
ensuite à descendre à dans les
différentes gammes on un écran intérieur
qui vous et 80% plus résistants par
rapport à la génération précédente sa
dragonne 188 ici on a 8 gigas de ram et
pas 12 giga de ram un smartphone qui
certifiait également ipx8 et que ce soit
sur les épaules de trois ans sur le 7
filles 3 et tourne sur un nuage basé sur
l'android 11 donc on est dans
l'expérience hameçon dans l'écosystème
samsung et l'écosystème samsung
s'agrandit je vous dis avec les montres
on en parlera plus tard également avec
des boys les bugs de vendre parlera
également probablement plus tard de leur
rythme ça vous intéresse qu on en parle
en bas dans les commentaires dites le
moi en rien un truc qui est intéressant
c'est qu'ici samsung a fait comme sur
les galaxy s 21 on a plus de blocs de
charge donc si vous achetez un de ces
deux smartphones si vous n'avez pas de
bloc de charges incluent tout sera donc
utilisé soit celui que vous avez
actuellement soit en achetant
directement dans le store de samsung
d'ailleurs s'il vous intéresse et
modèles vous aimez les liens en bas
juste en bas dans la description alors
au terme de tarifs qu'est ce que ça
raconte tout ça ça raconte que sur votre
zone paul ii iii et bien vous le
trouverez la version 256 go à
1799 euros ça reste quand même un
certain budget nous on est passionné
très haut de gamme là-dessus clairement
et la version 512 jegham on est à 1899
euros un peu en dessous des deux mille
euros mais en relisant de l'ultra haut
de gamme et je vous dis une fois de plus
pas de bol de charger pas de style et
ses souvenirs l'acheter en plus et là où
c'est vraiment intéressant et merci
samsung la démocratisation elle arrive
par le z philippe iii lorsque vous le
trouvez à un petit peu plus de 1000
euros on reste à notre très haut de
gamme on reste vraiment dans
l'excellence aujourd'hui haut niveau
chez samsung 1059 euros pour la version
128 giga de stockage c'est le tarif d'un
s-21 plus à sa sortie en tout cas vous
voyez que ça reste très cher mais malgré
tout on se rapproche vraiment du grand
public il coûtait à peu près 1500 euros
à sa sortie sur la première version donc
sa deuxième version on a quand même
perdu 500 euros c'est beaucoup plus
abordable pour venir démocratiser ici
une fois de plus le pliable et sur la
version 256 go de stockage vous êtes à
1109 euros c'est 1 50 euro + sont des
produits qui sont très bien qu'ils
continuent à évoluer la certification la
caméra sous l'écran lé pa dann bann mais
malgré tout elle est là et on voit le
progrès donc je trouve ça intéressant on
détestera je vous ferai mon retour
complet un peu plus tard on les aura
probablement à la fin du mois donc on se
revoit à la fin du mois pour en reparler
distillant par adolf ogi donne
évidemment mais on en reparlera entre
testera ses smartphones parce que c'est
vraiment intéressant d'essayer de voir
les usages qu'on peut faire les limites
on essaiera avec le stylet sur les
épaules de trois on essaiera lezennes
philippe iii également en mobilité parce
que ça raconte on regarde tout ça bien
évidemment avec les nouvelles smartwatch
de samsung voir si elles sont
intéressantes et pertinentes et comment
est ce que ray samsung est réussi salé
l'ass avec google au niveau de cette
nouvelle expérience logiciel dans tout
ça on reviendra plus tard d'ici là je
vous invite à venir tout ce que vous en
pensez vous en bas en commentaire et si
vous avez des questions posées mois
toutes vos questions dès maintenant sur
ses produits en bas en commentaire je
vous y répondrait lors de ma vidéo lors
de mes vidéos de test au calaisis dès
maintenant marquer moi en bas on
commentaires toutes vos questions comme
ça je vous dirai tout très bientôt d'ici
là portez vous bien les robes et doute
de l'amo et à bientôt ciao